[Music]
13 reasons why is by far one of the most
controversial shows on television but
wait until you hear about an unedited
moment that made us think season two
originally had a completely different
ending that would have made this show
even more brutal don't forget to hit
that notification valve to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out 10 mistakes in 13
reasons why a random woman people had a
lot to say about season 2 and even more
so about its final scene but we'll talk
more about the other stuff
for now let's focus on one of the most
emotional moments ever when we hear the
night we met come on at the ball the
song which was declared as clay in
Hannah's love song hit him and us pretty
hard and many of us were crying as we
watched the group hug clay and help him
get through it
but if you were crying too hard you
probably missed this strange moment
right as the song starts playing we see
the camera focusing on clay but in the
background we can also see a woman in
white who seems to be patting someone on
the back people have pointed out that
she looks like someone who was making
sure the dancers in the back were
positioned correctly for the shot on the
other hand some people think that it
could also be a chaperone either way it
really looks like the person was not
supposed to be there she looked way out
of place what do you think a chaperone
or a behind the scenes person 12 plans
reasons one of the most talked about
elements of this show are without a
doubt the tapes they were controversial
and a frequent 13 reasons why debate
topic but what seems to be confusing
some is the number of the actual tapes
if you saw the first season you probably
know the order of the tapes it starts
with a Justin who also gets a second
tape later on Hannah also mentions
Jessica Zach
Tyler clay and plenty of other people
with the last person that's mentioned is
mr. Porter who failed to help Hanna even
though she very clearly explains what
had happened here's where things get a
bit weird this mistake was pointed out
several times but probably went
unnoticed by most in the beginning of
the show you hear Hannah say that there
are 13 sides to the tapes because there
are 13 sides to every story
people have pointed out that there's no
way they would have been
thirteen tapes at the beginning because
in the episode with mr. Porter pana
asks her mom for a tape so she can
record an extra one
so how come Hannah still said there were
13 sides the timeline of her tape
recordings is unclear did she record the
intro after all 13 tapes were recorded
or was it really a continuity error
mysterious door the first season was
without a doubt some of the most
heart-wrenching moments you'll probably
ever see on television but even more
happens in episode 12 so much is going
on that it actually makes you stop
focusing on the details this error
happens in one of the earlier scenes of
episode 12 where we see just getting
scared when she finds Justin in her room
after Jess says she's going to call the
police
Justin tells her he was trying to
protect her after we see just close the
door the pay attention to that door you
can clearly see it closed fully right in
several shots after when Jess stands in
front of the door you can actually still
see it closed but when Justin stands in
front of the door you can actually see
it slightly ajar in the first shot but
when Jess says Justin's just trying to
make excuses for Bryce the door shut
again strange right necklace the 12th
episode of season 1 is definitely one of
the most triggering episodes you'll ever
see so even if you want to re-watch it
to catch these mistakes we should warn
you the same goes for the next few
seconds of this video as we'll talk
about moments before one of the most
horrifying scenes of the first season
this next mistake happens right before
the traumatic hottub scene when Hanna is
in the hot tub by herself you can
clearly see the necklace around her neck
there's no visible clasp which means
it's probably at the back of her neck
where it should be then as soon as Bryce
comes in the hot tub the clasp of the
necklace suddenly moved further down and
it's clearly visible this could be of
course caused by the hot tub water
however the necklace doesn't seem to
move at all in any other moments of
course this mistake could have been
easily overlooked considering what
happened to Hanna after Bryce came in
the hot tub and it's such a minor error
compared to some of the others we'll
mention in this video we have a feeling
even Hannah's necklace knew Bryce wasn't
up to any good in this scene and we
really can't blame it change of scenery
the final scene of season 1 was probably
one of the most scenic moments you'll
find in this
show we see toning in the gang drive off
in this iconic vintage car as Tony asks
that chilling question what he should
put on a tape but pay attention to the
background on Tony's side you can
actually see a lot of greenery and even
something that looks like a large body
of water in the back the same landscape
can be found on clay side they look like
they're on a highway that's surrounded
by the ocean but when the camera zooms
out of the car and focuses on the
landscape the scenery changes the
greenery is still there but now all you
can see the houses especially on Tony's
left side which showed a lot of water
just a few seconds before this still
there appears to be some kind of body of
water as the camera shows a higher
perspective but it definitely doesn't
look as big as it did in the background
especially not on Tony's left side this
one was probably just a green screen
mistake but it's a mistake nevertheless
perfect circle's rewatching 13 reasons
why it's a painful experience and we
can't imagine a lot of people watching
this show over and over again but if you
have you probably noticed this mistake
Alex played a pretty complicated part in
Hannah's life and it's a reminder that
we should always be cautious about our
friends agenda after Hannah finds out
what Alex did to her and how he put her
on the spot in front of everybody she
adds him to the tape to pay attention to
how she circles his name when she puts
him on her list it's a completely
different circle to the circle you see
later on when we can see some of the
other names on the list in fact once we
see the complete list every circle looks
like it's almost perfectly oval but when
it was actually circled by Hannah
herself the circle looked a lot
different even though the writing of his
name is exactly the same it could be
that she wrote the names again later on
or you know that this was just another
small detail that the director thought
no one will really pay enough attention
to a change of font in episode 7 of
season 1 Hannah actually did something
really brave she confronted Zach who she
confided in especially since Zack showed
that he genuinely liked her for who she
is and not for anything else or any
other rumor spreading but things
backfire when Hannah finds out Zach has
been emptying her compliments bag which
was set up for students to share
anonymous calm
hang a left is a Collette ur and Zack
later showed it to clay in the letter
Hanna explained how lonely she felt and
it was yet another cry for help to pay
attention to see how she wrote his name
on the letter you can see it when she
puts it in Zacks bag that when Zack
hands a letter to clay you can see that
his name is written and positioned it's
slightly different than in this teen
where Hanna puts it in the bag you can
clearly see the difference in the letter
H as well as the placement of the
letters D the cast members must have two
different versions of the note but
someone still did a great job at trying
to recreate it in the best way possible
glass of water seriously if you've
already seen both seasons re-watch them
and focus on the background details
you'd be surprised by what you can
actually catch as Tony's mother would
say first you have to eat then do
everything else but this mistake can be
spotted as Tony and clay are actually
eating turn tape number 6 to side a and
fast-forward to the restaurant scene
with Tony clay and sky sky hands the
boys two glasses of water but pay
attention as the camera focuses on clay
you can actually see Tony pick up the
glass of water several times but we
never actually see him drink it from the
front check it out when sky asks if they
had a tough night you can see him reach
out for the glass but in the front shot
he's not holding anything and in the
next shot he's actually holding the
glass and it really does look like he's
drinking but as the camera goes back to
the front he's pretty much focused on
talking and eating even though it looks
like the other characters are still
doing everything they were supposed to
do more extras don't worry we're not
done yet you can find this mistake in
season 2 episode 4 called the second
polaroid so the talk between the
school's principal and mr. Porter might
not seem like a big deal that is if you
don't pay attention to the background
this one is actually quite surprising
and we're really amazed that they let it
slide because it's pretty obvious when
mr. Bolen said that they should get
parents involved you can see two kids
passing them by on the right but when
the camera focuses on mr. Bolen in the
second after you can actually see the
same two kids passing by again come on
guys we can understand the change of the
font or even the different shape of the
circle but at least make sure your
extras aren't all over the place we
can't even be sure if this
is just because of the editing as the
conversation between mister boland and
mr. Porter actually flows on as the
camera switches perspective
seriously they couldn't get someone else
to walk by again you can clearly see
that these are the same students a
different ending
no one seems to be sure whether this is
a mistake or just a weird detail that
suggested a different ending season two
finale was pretty controversial but
there's one hint that seems to suggest
season two really was delayed because of
the tragic event at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School during the very
final moments where we see clay have fun
with his friends you can actually hear
an echo of what appears to be someone
shouting that someone else has a gun and
by now we all know that this someone was
Tyler so while it's not clear whether
people on the inside knew about Tyler
some people suspect that this was a hint
that the show would have had a different
ending it's not clear whether this was
an actual mistake or if the background
character actually said something
completely different either way we have
a feeling that going in a different
direction with that scene was probably
the best option considering how many
people had very strong opinions about 13
reasons why what do you think was that
echo a detail that forgot to be edited
out by the crew come let us know in the
comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
[Music]